welcome to my cesspool of bigotry and
hate the leftist hyenas at Media Matters
have made a seven minute video
compilation and 2500 word article
smearing this show and the rest of the
daily wire gang as a cesspool of bigotry
and hate do you know why it's because we
suggested that it is wrong to kill
babies after they've already been born
and because we suggested that men are
not women that's actually in the video I
think we're gonna use it as a best-of
compilation we examine the real bigots
and haters from Media Matters those
scum-sucking leeches all the way to Joe
Biden currently leading the pack of 2020
Democratic presidential candidates then
actress Rosanna Arquette apologizes for
being white and I forgive her Huffington
Post publishes the dumbest article on
the Internet today and finally the
mailbag I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
yes come on into my cesspool we are
going to mire ourselves in a truly
national cesspool of bigotry and hate
though it's not on the right it's on the
left we'll get to that in a second but
first I have got to help you out help me
help you starting at just $10 per month
you can never have to worry about hair
loss again hair loss affects so many
guys and it can start very young it can
start when you're between 25 35 years
old it's easy to stop but you've got to
get started right now getting started is
super easy signing up takes less than
five minutes over it keeps just answer a
few simple questions snap some photos to
complete your online doctor consultation
a licensed physician will review your
information online and recommend the
right treatment for you then it is
shipped right to your door every three
months it's easy you don't need to think
about it again keeps offers generic
versions of the only two fda-approved
hair loss products out there keeps
treatments are up to 90% effective at
reducing and stopping further hair loss
you can stop it it's not hard to do but
you've got to start now some men
experience hair regrowth and at best men
will get back up to 20% of the hair
they've already lost how much does it
cost
virtually nothing it's just 10 to 35
bucks a month think of all the stupid
stuff you waste 10 bucks on right now by
the way you can get your first month
free I'll tell you guys I'm not exactly
a hulking Adonis of a man okay I'm not
the captain of the football team over
here but I've always done fairly well
with the ladies and why is it because I
got a nice spate of Italian hair on my
head make sure you don't lose that it's
so easy if you suffer from hair loss the
last thing you need is to wait to go see
a doctor with keeps there is finally a
way to get the help you need when you
need it for a limited time receive your
first month of treatment for free go to
keeps calm / Knolls ke eps calm / Knolls
KO wles for your first month of
treatment for free all right I will get
to media matters in a second I want to
save Media Matters as sort of my entree
today I want to whet my appetite I
really want to get
I want to salivate a little bit before I
dig into those scum-sucking leeches at
the political outfit Media Matters and
Parker Malloy who is the head of it and
some of the other people there a media
matters by the I'll just remind you
Media Matters was a favorite
organization of the Ohio shooter just to
remind you well they're blaming the
right for all sorts of awful violence
and bigotry just wanted to remind you
that the Ohio shooter regularly
retweeted Media Matters bunch of scum
sucking leeches we'll get to them in a
second first I want to zoom out a little
bit though and get to the 2020
presidential race because the left has
now turned the racial divisiveness and
turned the invective and turned the
insults all the way up to 11 not just
the silly frivolous candidates like beta
or orc but all the way up to the
front-runner Joe Biden so-called
moderate Joe so every man Joe that guy
is now referring to President Trump as a
white supremacist used to be racist
now they've called conservatives racists
forever with absolutely no basis for it
then it was white nationalist that's and
that's the reason they use the term
white nationalists is because
conservatives have embraced nationalism
I mean Irving Kristol in the 1960s
described conservatism as religion
nationalism and economic growth so what
they want to do is tie nationalism a
perfectly legitimate concept with white
nationalism which is an incoherent
concept because there has never been a
nation of the whites there is no ethnic
group called the whites with a capital W
there are ethnic nations like England or
Italy or France or Germany but there's
no nation of the whites so they take
this incoherent concept called white
nationalism and they use it to try to
convince idiots that conservatives are
bigots now they've turned this all the
way up again they've called us white
supremacists here is Joe Biden giving a
campaign speech yesterday a comparing
Donald Trump to the segregationist
candidate George Wallace indeed we have
a president with a toxic tongue
it was publicly and unapologetically
embraced the political strategy of hate
racism and division so it's up to us as
it was in the 20s it's up to us we're
living through a rare moment in this
nation in history where our president
isn't up to the moment where our
president lacks the moral authority to
lead where our president has more in
common with George Wallace than he does
with George Washington yeah Trump is a
white supremacist you see he's awful by
the way don't forget Joe Biden just got
shanked by Kamala Harris at the first
Democratic presidential debate because
he was extolling the virtues of
segregationists not one month ago one
month ago this guy who has the audacity
to call Donald Trump a white supremacist
was extolling the virtues of
segregationists this guy during the 2008
presidential race referred to Barack
Obama is the first black guy who was
clean and articulate and he said that's
a fairy tale man he was so shocked it
couldn't possibly be the case that in
reality a black man is clean and
articulate Joe Biden was shocked by that
that guy this guy from the political
party of slavery the Ku Klux Klan Jim
Crow lynchings that guy Joe Biden has
the audacity to call President Trump and
conservatives white supremacists now Joe
Biden though he launches this attack he
obviously can't back it up with facts so
the only way he can back up this
narrative that Trump is a white semi to
magic Donald Trump the guy you've known
since the 1980s real estate mogul casino
guy reality TV star for 15 years won
awards literally next to Rosa Parks old
Palin around with Al Sharpton Jesse
Jackson that guy that we've all known
for 50 years
turns out secretly he's a white
supremacist that's the narrative that
Joe Biden now needs to sell because the
Democratic primary has become so
radicalized and so disengaged from
reality so he can back it up with facts
therefore he has to back it up with
obvious demonstrable lies
here is how he justifies the claim that
Trump is a white supremacist how far
apart are those comments how far is it
from white supremacist and neo-nazis in
charlottesville trump's very fine people
chanting you will replace us to the
shooter at the Tree of Life synagogue in
Pittsburgh
there it is Trump's very fine people so
that this is the lie this is the
foundational legend of the Trump is a
white supremacist thing which is the
Donald Trump called neo-nazis and white
supremacists very fine people in
Charlottesville they are all saying this
Joe Biden launched his presidential
campaign on this lie so here is very
quickly fifty seconds or a minute the
full unedited unvarnished no movie magic
going on clip of what President Trump
said when he used the phrase very fine
people in Charlottesville you can hear
very clearly he explicitly condemns the
people that Joe Biden says Trump called
very fine people but you also had people
that were very fine people on both sides
you had people in that group excuse me
excuse me I saw the same pictures as you
did you had people in that group that
were there to protest the taking down of
to them a very very important statue and
the renaming of a park from robert e lee
to another name washington was a slave
owner was george washington a slave
owner so will George Washington now lose
his status are we gonna take down excuse
me are we going to take down are we
going to take down statues to George why
how about Thomas Jefferson what do you
think of Thomas Jefferson you like him
okay good are we going to take down the
statue because he was a major slave
owner now we going to take down his
statue so you know what it's fine you're
changing history you're changing culture
and you had people and I'm not talking
about the neo-nazis and the white
nationalist because they should be
condemned
totally there you have it that clip was
one minute and three seconds long within
one minute and three seconds he uses the
phrase very fine people I mean he says
that phrase a little bit into it so you
have within certainly within a minute
you have Trump using the phrase very
fine people and then explicitly stating
that he's not calling neo-nazis and
white supremacists and white
nationalists very fine people that they
should be condemned
totally but this is all Joe Biden's got
because Joe Biden is a liar he's a
pathological liar he's hasn't just told
that kind of lies that politicians tell
he's told some very sick lies even lying
about the death of his own wife we'll
get to that in one second well we'll get
to what a shell of a man Joe Biden is
but first I've got to thank our friends
over at movement mbm T you know how much
I love movement I get more compliments
on my movement watch than than any watch
I've ever owned this is the revolver
collection four movements super cool
super sleek movement also has sunglasses
and the thing I love about sunglasses
I'm a sunglasses aficionado I think it's
because of my Italian heritage I always
want the best sunglasses I have an
extensive collection because I feel like
you wear them every day they're on your
face they affect literally how you see
the world so you just you don't want to
cheap out on it you want to invest I've
spent hundreds and hundreds of dollars
on one pair of sunglasses fortunately
now because of movement the same
innovation they brought two watches they
brought two sunglasses you can get
beautiful sunglasses some of the coolest
Styles really great quality stuff for a
fraction of the price that you would pay
in a department store you can do that
they pass the savings along to you
especially because they were first an
online company you get free shipping and
return so if you don't like them that's
fine you know it's not a huge deal
pick a style or design that you
personally like you know you can get one
what do you get it for like unbelievable
prices get a second one get a third one
it doesn't matter I like I really like
this design of the watch I really like
the design of the pair of glasses I have
I'll buy multiple because it movements
prices you can just start a collection
they're great they start at 60 bucks no
pair costs more than $95 they've sold
over 2.5 million products in more than
160 countries you've got to go check it
out 15% off today with free shipping and
free returns go to nvm t.com slash
Knowles KO wles cy movement keeps
growing check out the expanding
collection MVM t-dot-com / Knowles Kino
wles
join the movement Joe Biden is lying
this is the there is a foundational lie
to his presidential campaign which is
the Donald Trump called neo-nazis very
fine people in Charlottesville this is
now the foundational lie in this stupid
speech he gave yesterday this is no
surprise that Biden is lying he had to
leave the 1988 presidential campaign
because he lied about his law school
records that's why he had to get out of
that race he lied about his law school
records then he plagiarized a speech
from an Irish politician and then he
lied about that too but it's not just
those kind of lies that Joe Biden tells
because look politicians exaggerate
they'd bend the truth sometimes they
tell untruths without without even
meaning to the thing about Joe Biden is
that he's a pathological liar and he
tells really vile lies for instance Joe
Biden will often talk about how his wife
died right at the beginning of his
political career and it's this awful
tragedy that he had to live through and
his daughter died that I mean it was
just really awful but Joe Biden doesn't
just keep it to that story he repeatedly
lies about the circumstances of him to
impune the other driver who was involved
in that car accident to impugn his his
motives and his character and to malign
him and to make himself appear more of a
victim don't just take my word for it
don't just take the word of the right
wing for it the Atlantic a left-wing
magazine called Joe Biden at 4:00 this
in 2010 they wrote quote for many years
Biden described the driver of the truck
that struck and killed his first wife
and their daughter in December 1972 as a
drunk which he apparently was not the
tale could hardly be more tragic why in
a why add in a baseless charge the
family of the truck driver has labored
to correct the record but Biden made the
reference to drunkenness as recently as
2007 needlessly resurrecting a false and
painful allegation
why would Biden do this I mean it's so
to exploit your wife's death is is one
aspect of it but then to rewrite what
happened and take a guy who was not a
drunk driver by all accounts who
obviously feels awful for this accident
that happened and then as you the Vice
President of the United States to
publicly and wrongly smear him as a
drunk driver outrageous stuff but but
Biden is a pathological liar that's all
he's got he is a totally hollow shell of
a man who whose skin is artificial whose
hair is artificial and his teeth are
artificial and obviously whose thoughts
and rhetoric or artificial as well so
but Biden keeps up this charge he goes
full throated for it and he calls Trump
a white supremacist I don't think it's
that far at all it's both clear language
and in code this president's fanned the
flames of white supremacy in this nation
he's fanned the flames of white
supremacy okay this is the new line it's
not just Biden who's using this
Elizabeth Warren Pocahontas told the New
York Times without hesitation quote
Trump gave comfort to white supremacists
he's done the wink and a nod he has
talked about white supremacists as fine
people we just we just heard that that
isn't true so Elizabeth Warren using
this lie - he's done everything he can
to stir up racial conflict and hatred in
this country is that right well we'll
examine if that's right in a second beta
or orc a future or former presidential
candidate called President Trump a white
supremacist in no uncertain terms here
is on MSNBC and right now the president
is on the tarmac reading members of the
Texas delegation
he's on El Paso's soil what goes through
your head here in that well I think this
is the answer to that you have all these
beautiful people from El Paso but also
from ceylon Juarez Chihuahua Mexico our
sister city who are coming together in
the wake of this horrific loss of life
this terrorism that was in part inspired
by President Trump in his
of invasions and infestations his
demonization of this community
immigrants as rapists and criminals
there's a very real consequences it
doesn't just offend us it hurts us and
it kills us hold on we've got to stop it
there before he gets to calling Trump a
white supremacist because look at look
at the two things he's just said he said
the shooter was inspired by Trump we
know this isn't true the shooter himself
wrote in the manifesto I was not
inspired by Trump I had these views much
earlier so that part it just seems
obviously the shooter can lie but I
don't know why he would tell that lie
the second second part which is the most
absurd in the whole discussion his bado
of work talks about the targeting of
Hispanics as us he's hurting us he's
killing us who is us bado or work has
pretended to be Hispanic for his entire
political career not for his whole life
but for his political career bado our
work his real name is Robert Frances
O'Rourke he's completely Irish and he's
pretended to be Hispanic he talks in
broken garbled Spanglish on the
democratic debate stage because he knows
the rest of the party is all a bunch of
liberal white people so they're not
going to understand that he's just
totally mangling the Spanish language
but this guy actually has the gall after
being called out on this so many times
in his career to say it's us it's
killing us who it's killing billionaire
Irish guys that that that's who Donald
Trump's hate is killing is is
billionaire Irish dudes and
skateboarders no he's implying that it's
killing Hispanics and he's pretending to
be Hispanic which he's always been doing
but then he goes on he actually gets to
the meetup and he says Trump is a white
supremacist you've been very clear that
you believe the president is a racist is
the president a white supremacist he is
he's also made that very clear he's made
it very clear has he obviously bado or
work said it bado would never lie about
like you know even to the most important
aspects of his own identity he would
never tell a lie like that
so obviously president Trump has made it
very clear that he is a white
supremacist forget what he said a couple
days ago when he said that that hatred
warps the soul and it's it's all
terrible and awful and we need to be
united in condemned bigotry we know many
many other times president Trump has
rais'd racism and bigotry and white
supremacy has a near olloclip racism is
evil and those who cause violence in its
name are criminals and thugs including
the KKK neo-nazis white supremacist and
other hate groups that are repugnant to
everything we hold dear as Americans and
I'm not talking about the neo-nazis and
the white nationalists because they
should be condemned
totally we are a nation founded on the
truth that all of us are created equal
we are equal in the eyes of our Creator
we are equal under the law and we are
equal under our Constitution those who
spread violence in the name of bigotry
strike at the very core of America how
many times do I have to reject I've
reject David Duke rejected David Duke
I've rejected the KKK the Ku Klux Klan
from the time I'm five years old that
rejected them I put it on Twitter last
week now I haven't been asked this
question so many times yeah yeah okay
all right Donald
it's just what a white supremacist would
say okay condemning repeatedly racism
and bigotry and white supremacy for
years and years and years just but
that's really convenient isn't it but a
white supremacist would love to say
those things huh not buying it buddy
Bernie Sanders jumping on this to
calling Trump a white supremacist this
is the new line of attack and Biden is
embracing it because he has no
principles and he's shameless and he
doesn't care if he tears the country
apart and he's happy to to stir up a
cesspool of hatred and bigotry and he
needs to keep it up so that this is the
line he needs to keep it up if he wants
to keep up with the pack of other wacko
radicals in the 2020 Democratic primary
so Biden realizes he's got to address
the fact that Trump repeatedly condemns
white supremacy and bigotry and hatred
so here is how Biden chooses to do it he
says it's all just words and Trump
doesn't really mean any of it he's
low-energy
vacant I'd mouthing the words written
for him
condemning white supremacist this week I
don't believe fooled anyone at home or
abroad whoa man this is a boy I know
that some intern or whoever wrote this
speech really thought yeah I'll call
Trump Low Energy because he calls us Low
Energy and Jeb Lo and that's what we'll
call him Low Energy will say that he
doesn't really believe it we'll say that
he's he's just vacantly
mouthing words that were written for him
the trouble with that is that it isn't
true the reason that Trump's attacks
work is because they're true Jeb Bush
really does have low energy a Joe Biden
really does look sleepy you don't have
to look any further than the last
presidential debate when Joe Biden stood
vacant I'd bungling the words and
mouthing the words that someone else had
written for him let's listen to this
clip three oh three three three oh three
oh if you agree with me go to Joe 303
300 a fight thank you very much so
obviously he's projecting the left
always projects will explain how they're
doing that on hate hate filled bigotry
cesspool in a second but he Joe Biden at
least because he's a practice politician
has to try to tie this argument together
so he has to try to make an argument for
how all of this fits in the shootings
and the hatred and the bigotry and the
guns and the Donald Trump and he tries
to wrap it up here at the end of the
speech this is and this is really saying
something the least coherent argument
I've ever heard from Joe Biden he's
trying to tie these things together
hatred mental health and guns all in the
old with relation to president Trump see
if you can make any sense of how he
tries to do it he says guns are not the
problem in mass shootings the issue is
mental health
it's a dodj hatred isn't a mental health
issue okay let's just try to examine
that for a second that last line hatred
is not a mental hell
issue so so what Joe Biden is saying is
this is a Dodge when Trump wants to talk
about mental health instead of guns with
regard to these shootings it's a Dodge
because hatred is not a mental health
issue
first of all yes it is hatred is a
mental issue it is entirely a mental
issue it is a faculty in your mind your
mind is is perceiving certain things and
coming to certain conclusions your
faculties of reason are the ones that
are ending up in a hate-filled view of
the world or your faculties of unreason
in in the case of mental health problems
so hatred is a mental health issue but
what about the dodge on guns or is
hatred a gun issue is hatred a firearms
issue he says it's a dodge hatred isn't
a mental health issue it's a
manufacturing issue it's an ammunition
issue it's a firearms issue no no it's
not hatred is a mental issue right
hatred is metaphysical it's it's the
product of our ideas and sometimes our
own incoherence and our perception of
the world hatred whatever hatred is is
not a physical issue and guns are
physical guns are just a hunk of metal
and a hunk of plastic hatred does not
pertain to guns because guns are
physical objects you need a mental
decision a mental perception a mental
cause of action to make you pick up the
gun and pull the trigger
so what Joe is doing is he's just using
words like they all do they just kind of
use words randomly to give the sound of
an argument even though it isn't an
argument this relates to a personal
story our friends over at Media Matters
which a lot of people don't know what
media matters is a lot of media people
do but to the rest of the world what
we're told is that media matters is a
media watchdog group but they're not a
media watchdog group they are a leftist
political organization that solely
exists to get right-wing media figures
fired from their jobs so they've been
trying to get ruch fired forever they've
been trying to get Tucker Carlson fired
they've been trying to get sean hannity
fired now I guess they're trying to get
me fired they want to get all of them
fired and
you'll notice the right doesn't have
this because we're not afraid of MSNBC
running their mouths on cable we know
that our arguments are better than
theirs so we're going to beat them in
the court of public opinion because the
left knows that their arguments are so
bad they have to just try to shut us up
so they try to censor us on social media
they try to censor us on campus they try
to censor us in the workplace and now
they try to censor our TV shows and our
podcasts and our radio shows that's what
Media Matters is doing so they put
together a seven minute long clip they
tweet it out they said we watched all of
these hours of daily wire footage and
we've concluded this is a cesspool of
bigotry and hate here's our report and
I'll just play you a brief clip that's
like a 30-second clip from a seven
minute long compilation this is the kind
of Content that Media Matters is trying
to convince people is hateful and
bigoted I think that it is worse to
slaughter babies after they've been born
than to wear blackface abortion helps
rapists cover up their crimes you are
just not a decent person if you support
giving lethal injection to infants
abortion doctor number four is a
problematic term because it includes the
word doctor I would suggest the term
medical assassin there is obviously
something wrong in that house of Islam
there is a lot more evidence that Ilhan
Omar has sympathies for al-qaeda then
there is the Donald Trump is a racial
bigot this is this is the best stuff
this is what the Media Matters scoured
all of our content how many hundreds how
many thousands of hours of content is
there from our shows I mean I've done
about 400 shows myself and I'm pretty
much the newest show at The Daily wire
how many shows if the other guys done
700 or something like that how many
thousands of hours have they gone
through and the best they could find the
best example of bigotry was that I said
that it is worse to slaughter babies
after they have been born than to wear a
racially insensitive costume it's the
best they've got that's what they put
forward obviously I stand by all of it I
think this should be an advertiser promo
video for us I think we should put this
video out there as a subscriber pitch it
shows us that the Left projects this is
what they do they call us racists
because they are racists
they call us bigots because they are
bigots they call us hateful because they
are hateful we're not just look at any
conservative generally speaking we stay
pretty calm
generally speaking we talk about unity
we talk about love of country we talk
about how the other side isn't evil
they're just very very wrong and we need
to convince them to be right what does
the left do I mean just look at these
terror attacks over the weekend these
shootings the one guy in Texas was an
eco fascist he had aspects of his
ideology that I guess you would call
right-wing and aspects that you would
call far left-wing the shooter in Ohio
was a an avowed leftist a socialist a an
endorser of Elizabeth Warren and yes a
fan of Media Matters this cesspool of
hatred that published the hit piece on
us the the Ohio shooter literally
reposted Media Matters content to his
social media pages and they blame us
because they project anything that is
true of them they try to accuse us of
they are the haters they are the bigots
they lie about what we say they Doc's us
or nearly Doc's us the way that a
Joaquin Castro did just a couple days
ago
they commit terror attacks like occurred
at the ice facility we don't know the
motive of the Ohio shooter but we do
know he was an avowed leftist they
Gaslight us they try to strip us of our
rights they are a cesspool and the
reason I bring this up now is it's only
August of 2019 we went from racist to
white nationalists to white supremacists
in the eyes of the left more than a year
out from the 2020 election how much
hotter is this going to get what are
they going to be calling us next
November they'll call us baby killers I
mean I guess that's the worst thing I
can imagine as being a baby killer and I
guess they'll probably call us that
because they always project what they do
and they literally kill babies and they
say that killing babies is a human right
and it's wonderful and it should be
celebrated and shouted from the rooftops
I do think this is gonna backfire this
is the deplorable thing all over again
this is Hillary calling half the country
deplorable turns out that doesn't help
you win presidential elections doesn't
help you bring people over your cause
they talk about Trump's base what is
Trump's base
what let's call Trump's pace 60 million
people voted for him you figure say 10
or 20 million of that is independent or
more moderates of 40 million Americans
are white supremacists and neo-nazis
that's what they're saying okay keep it
up guys keep it up
yep call him deplorable and irredeemable
and Nazis that's great can't wait to see
how that serves you in the 2020 election
the madness of all of it rosanna
arquette from the arquette acting family
tweeted out yesterday quote I'm sorry I
was born white and privileged it
disgusts me I feel so much shame
that's the madness in their heads Rosana
I forgive you you were absolved I
forgive you it's okay I think a lot of
this is because the left doesn't have
religion and they don't have true
religion and so because everybody's got
to serve somebody because you will guide
your your human nature toward some
religious idea politics becomes their
religion but there's no absolution there
we have a broken human nature and
because there is no redemption in the
politics of leftism there is just shame
and shame and guilt and bile and vitriol
and bigotry and a cesspool of hatred and
you see this a very we don't have time
to go through the article but this is
the dumbest article on the internet
today it's from The Huffington Post it
might be time to cut my right wing Trump
loving in-laws out of my kids lives and
they go on to describe these just like
grandparents these just regular
grandparents who they oppose illegal
immigration they are Catholic they
adhere to a traditional sexual morality
they don't think that men are women they
don't buy the kind of fashions of the
sexual revolution and this woman says
because my in-laws are conservative
because they hold a political view that
half of the country holds because they
go to church on Sundays because they're
Catholic I cannot allow my children to
see them she writes she says I always
yell at them on Facebook and I always
tweet text them these Long's Creed's
about how awful they are and how they
need to change their minds and then she
complained she said at one point the
mother-in-law writes back and says thank
you for your note so she says okay thank
you I've heard your point of view
but she says because they won't change
because they won't become liberals and
they won't become atheists the kids they
can't see their grandchildren that is
the definition of hatred that is the
definition of bigotry that is a cesspool
and it's not just there's no moral
equivalence it's not that the left and
the right both have this kind of
cesspool of hatred and bigotry they
don't it's not even close it's just the
left it is 99.9% the left and it's not
just some random guy on Twitter
it's Media Matters those scum-sucking
hyenas it's all the way up to Joe Biden
obviously it's bado it's Elizabeth
Warren it's all the way up to even Joe
Biden leader of the pack so called
moderate willing to malign half of his
countrymen whom he hates whose guts
he hates willing to malign them as white
supremacist bigots Nazis supporters of
white supremacists when they say this to
us you know what I say to them okay so
what keep it up keep it up guys
see how many elections you win so many
minds you change their hatred warps
people's own minds it makes people's own
lives much worse doesn't make my life
worse that the fact that Media Matters
went through and did a best-of
compilation of my show
thanks thanks guys you saved me hours of
work now I can tweet that out there
doesn't hurt me hatred doesn't degrade
me being smeared as a bigot doesn't
degrade me it degrades the people who
are doing it and it's degrading now the
leaders of the Democratic Party that's
where our our country is it's sad that
half of this country the left despises
the other half but what can I say we'll
be the adults we'll be here when you
want to stop having your temper tantrum
and you want to grow up we've got to get
to the mail bag so we will do that now
go to daily wire calm you know what you
get you get everything my show the end
reclaim and show the ben shapiro show
the matt wall show you test questions in
the mailbag coming up you get to ask
questions of backstage you get another
Kingdom you get everything you get the
leftist tears tumblr guys it's August
2019 how much you will be drowning by
November 2020 if you don't get the
tumblr
head on over we'll be right back
from Chuck Michael
ideally parents and churches would teach
children morality and ethics but in a
world where this often does not occur
should this be taught in our public
schools the Bible should be taught in
our public schools certainly I mean the
Bible is the textual foundation of our
civilization it is the most important
book or many books that have ever been
written both because of their objective
truth what they tell us about the human
condition about who we are about our
relationship to our Creator but also for
people who are atheistic or agnostic or
who don't want to grant that premise it
has led to every work of art and
literature in Western civilization if
you don't know the Bible you can't know
anything else about Western civilization
and so just from a very practical
pedagogical level you need to teach the
Bible in schools I think we should do
that should we teach ethics
well ethics you would teach in in a
context of either religion religious
education or philosophy and I'm not sure
that a lot of middle schools and high
schools have philosophy classes so maybe
not in terms of morality I certainly
don't want that you know that kind of
very specific religious instruction in
public schools because the moral views
that are now held by the popular culture
are totally perverse I mean just to give
you one basic example pride is held up
as the greatest virtue we have a whole
month now to celebrate Pride and yet
pride is the deadliest of the seven
deadly sins so no I don't want public
schools teaching their own bizarre
version of morality but they do need to
teach the Bible and the thing is when
you present students with the greatest
works of our civilization the Bible and
of course the great poems and the great
great literature and real history not
third-string history but like actual
historical texts through Citadis for
example when you teach them that if
everything clicks into place they can
see their own civilization clearly they
can see the world much more clearly when
you deny them education in that regard
and you just teach them your own
ideological view of all of those things
then it warps their vision and and they
graduate
ignorant sometimes more ignorant than
they were when they were started I would
say just present to them the great works
and allow them to either come to their
own conclusions or hopefully have some
sort of moral ethical and religious
formation at home and in the Civic
society civil society from Nicole do you
have any advice on how to stay positive
during these times of disgust and hatred
toward conservatives I live in
California and I am so tired of being
called racist and recently responsible
for the shootings over the weekend I
have a lot of trouble making friends
because they eventually find out my
politics and I don't know where to go or
what to do thank you for all you do love
the show yes I do have advice on this
which is we always knew this was going
to happen we know that that in this
world which is run by the Prince of
Darkness the truth is despised people
don't like the truth they don't like the
light they prefer lies and they prefer
darkness people don't like freedom
people don't want to be freedom the
human heart does not yearn to be free
people generally speaking want to be
slaves they want to be told what to do
they want to be coddled they don't want
to rise up and-and-and-and into their
full humanity so obviously if you peddle
lies and you peddle saccharine nonsense
and you peddle leftist politics you're
going to be much more popular in this
world but it's wrong and so you're
choosing to speak the truth as you see
it and that's gonna cost your friends
it's gonna maybe cost you a job it's
gonna cost you a lot I mean that's
that's the price everything has a price
but I think they there is some hope for
you I mean on the one hand in the very
political near term you can have hope of
improving your country just by speaking
political truths and then in the eternal
realm when you are you know
Christ tells us this you'll have pains
and troubles in this world but take
heart I have overcome the world so I
don't really care I mean as particularly
I think Catholics have this kind of
sense that that suffering is sanctifying
so suffering isn't evil in and of itself
suffering is just a fact of life I mean
that's just a kind of that's the way the
world is what is moral is your reaction
to suffering so you can either react to
suffering by saying oh woe is me pity
pity me everything's terrible
gosh life is so bad or you can react to
suffering and say well I am binding up
in my flesh this suffering I'm kissing
it up to God I'm I'm becoming more
saintly I'm becoming more humble I'm
becoming more grateful for what I do
have we live in a great time and just
because there are a lot of slanderous
idiots out there defaming you doesn't
mean that we don't live in a great time
and doesn't mean that you don't have a
lot of opportunities to do good and you
can always find I've only lived in
left-wing places and I have somehow
managed to find a few conservatives to
be friends with Andy and even some
open-minded liberals obviously so I
think that's fine I would say take heart
it was ever thus it was ever thus that a
someone who is a contrarian to the
inherited truths of this world of this
particular terrestrial world was always
going to have a tough time but to take
heart because the world has been
overcome from Amanda hi Michael I'm a
new subscriber and I've heard you
mention a few times on your show that
you used to be an atheist when and why
did you turn to religion yes gladly I'm
happy I actually just did a show on this
yesterday with the radio host Patrick
coffin and podcasters Patrick coffin I
was a cradle Catholic I was baptized
right as a kid by the time I was
confirmed in the church I was about 13 I
would have considered myself an atheist
and this was for a few reasons most
importantly my pride and intellectual
hubris I was a precocious 13 year old
and I thought I was smarter and cleverer
than I was partly because there was a
sex abuse scandal in the Catholic Church
which disillusioned a lot of people
partly because the religion that was
presented to me was childish we were not
presented with the fullness of the faith
in in both the beauty of the liturgy and
in the intellectual tradition and in the
spiritual fullness of the faith and and
because there was a publishing fad that
was going on at that time called the New
Atheists Samuel sam Harris Daniel
Dennett Christopher Hitchens and Richard
Dawkins and as a 13 year old who was
arrogant
I found these arguments really
compelling and they're really compelling
for thirteen-year-old boys and that's
about it
once you become an adult you realize
that they don't make good arguments they
don't really make much of an argument at
all there are probably a dozen good
arguments for the existence of God the
evidence of God is everywhere but there
are 13 good arguments if you prefer to
go in that way that's what happened to
me
I found the ontological argument very
compelling when I was 18 got to college
everyone was an atheist and they were
all pretty smart but the smartest people
were Christians and particularly
Catholic Eastern Orthodox on their way
to more deeper liturgical traditions
with with greater history behind them
and so I thought that's a little strange
I wonder why that is
and it's no coincidence I think that the
smartest people in the history of the
world have all believed in an
extraordinarily similar conception of
religion and there are very few smart
atheists that you find over over time
and upon examination you realize there's
not really any good argument for atheism
and and the atheist arguments are
convincing in a sort of shallow way but
they don't explain virtually anything
that actually matters about our
experience of the world there they're
clear arguments the the atheist
arguments but they're shallow dr.
Johnson talked about this he famously
said shallows are clear and profound
things deep things are deep they're
murky they're not so clear if I can fit
my description of the universe onto a
little note card in a three bullet
manifesto probably I'm not going to be
able to describe all of reality and let
me ask you something can you describe
multivariable calculus to me right now
can you give me a 60 second summation of
all of the knowledge of mathematics or
all the knowledge we have of by all
or all the knowledge we have of physics
no now if you can't give me all the
knowledge in sixty seconds of the
physical sciences if you can't explain
to me even the physical world don't you
think it's a little silly to purport to
explain to me all of the metaphysical
world in that same amount of time you
know I would never go to Richard Dawkins
and say hey Richard I've never studied
evolutionary biology at all I've never
even taken a class on it but let me tell
you everything about it he would laugh
at me
rightly so and yet that's exactly what
Richard Dawkins does he has no
experience in theology whatsoever or
philosophy for that matter he's not a
maybe he's took a class once an
undergrad or something but he just
doesn't really have any serious thought
in those areas and yet he would pretend
that his one particular expertise in one
particular area of the physical sciences
qualifies him to describe the the
totality of metaphysical truth it's
laughable and it's the sort of thing
that precocious thirteen-year-old boys
get taken in by but when you think about
it a little more deeply you're not
ultimately this culminated in some
intellectual humility and and and after
that only at that point did the
religious experience occur coincidences
finding a book here and there finding
these strange coincidences in the world
and I ended up at a church in New York
called the Church of st. Michael by
father George Rutner who is a tremendous
priest and that was the moment when it
solidified we I could go on forever but
that's the short version okay final last
question here we go from Ivan hi Michael
I have a job interview tomorrow and your
experience what are some ways I could
best prepare beforehand besides the
usual advice of making sure I've answers
to commonly asked questions just for
some context this is a mid-level
position in HR and recruiting thanks a
million to keep up the great and
excellent work thank you I do have some
advice one is ya know the answers to all
the questions that you usually get
specifically know the answer to the
question what have you failed at
everyone bungles this question and the
so they'll say oh I sometimes I fail to
stop working so hard
you know sometimes I fail to strike a
work-life balance because of what a hard
worker I am you know sometimes I've
failed at not doing things perfectly and
it's just so pathetic and stupid or you
to stand there and stammer actually tell
them what you've failed at I'm sure
you've failed in a million things I
certainly have tell them be honest I've
found people really respect that other
other aspects of the job interview
things that have always helped me is
probably out of madness I don't think
it's quite the line between confidence
and madness is a little blurry the job
interviews that I've gone into that I've
really totally aced are the ones where I
didn't really care if I got the job
now you might really want this job you
might really care but you just got to go
in there and know if I don't get it it's
not the end of the world I am qualified
I am prepared I will do a good job it
would be great if it works out but the
sum total of my value in this world is
not placed in my getting this job and if
you do that you will just seem confident
it will help you in salary negotiations
and and other aspects of the onboarding
process so do that know that you you're
good you're ready you've you've prepared
for this you've got a good life ahead of
you and if you don't get this job you'll
get the next one because ultimately
there is a more of a guiding hand in
your life than just your own personal
will ok that's our show we got to get
out of here have a good weekend I will
be here the whole time in my cesspool of
bigotry and hate so please come back and
join me in my cesspool on Monday I'm
Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Noel's show
the Michael Knoll show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring our
senior producer is Jonathan hey
supervising producer Mathis Glover
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor
Dany D'Amico our audio mixer is Mike
Cora Mina hair and makeup by Jesuit
alvera production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Michael Nolt show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
if you prefer facts over feelings if you
aren't offended by the brutal truth
if you can still laugh at the nuttiness
filling our national news cycle well
tune on into the Ben Shapiro show or
you'll get a whole lot of that and much
more we'll see you there